[Music]
many people put off routine health exams
during the pandemic
but now that we're fully reopened again
it's time to take care of yourself
in today's buddy check 8 report denise
valdez
brings us the story of a local woman
whose fight against cancer
could have much different results had
she postponed
her routine screening pamela denney
is living proof that early detection
saves lives
aren't you glad that you had your
routine mammogram i mean you walked in
there was like oh this just business as
usual and it was not business as usual
absolutely and my surgeon was amazed i'm
amazed they found it so small like one
centimeter
size of a they said like an eraser on
the end of a pencil
a routine mammogram an ultrasound then
an mri guided biopsy
led to a dreaded diagnosis she called me
immediately in early november of 2019
and let me know that i did have breast
cancer it was
called invasive lobular carcinoma denny
credits a keen-eyed radiologist and
committed doctors for spotting it so
quickly
i've been told it's very small and i was
lucky it was stage one
[Music]
i thought well why not do the least
invasive thing go with a lumpectomy and
you know and then you do have to have
radiation after that she started
radiation in march of 2020.
just as the world was shutting down she
was starting the fight of her life
now more than a year later she reminds
every woman to
never take routine care for granted i
definitely
tell everyone that i know go get your
annual exam you just never know
in denny's case the cancer was caught
very early
giving her options and the time she
needed to make the right choice for her
for buddy check i'm denise faltes back
to you